να βοηθήσει στο παιδήσουν μπικά που στη δημόσιαν υπηρεσίας στο βαθμό που πλέο γίνεται διότι
ευτυχώς έχουν πει κάποιες διαδικασίες ιδύς στο κομμάτι των προσλήψεών που δεν είναι ςνέας δεν
είναι κίνον το πατεσκύλιαλέστε που ήταν απαλαιότερα ρά και τα κόμματα έχουν να αποδεκτεί σε
κάποιο βαθμόν το ρόλομ που τους απέμειναι δηλαδή ρουσφέρτι διευκολήνσης τα σύμβολα αυτά που είδαμε
τις τελευταίες μέρες δόγοικος της πεμτις με αρτίου και πρώτης απριλείου αυτά κάμνον τα κόμματα
σήμερα φοβούνται να δοκιμάσουν κάτι καινούριν μήπως και αποτίχουν και προσπαθούν να ακολουθούν την πεπατημένι
γνωρίζοντας και τα ίδια ότι είπεπατημένοι απλώς τους οδηγί ψε έναν τέλος απλώς θα πάρει
το χρόνον του αυτό τ ταλείδαμε όμως και τον νέο που ήταν το φανόμενο το
φιδία που βλέπουμε τώρα κάποια σκινήσεις του να ενοχλούν ιδιαίτερα ποιος ενοχλον ι διαίτερα και
τα κόμματα ι άκουσαμε και τον αρχεπίσκοπο χθες με κάποιος δηλώσεις του ήταν έντονοσε ότι
αφορά των φιδία θερίς οι αυτόν το φαινόμενο του φιδία κάπου ξεφουσκόνι ή θα δούμε
και άλλου φιδίες τα επόμενα χρόνιατώρα πριν πάμε στο φιδίανόμως επειδήσεις ε τούσαμε για τα
κόμματα δεν είναι όλα τα κόμματα στην κατιούσα τα μας αρέσειτει δεν μας αρέση έχουμε
ν ένα κόμμα υ ακο ελάνομα νελά το οποίον ή αυξάνει όχι απλώστά ποσωστά τουαυξάνει
τους πραγματικούς ψήφους που παίρνει σε κάθε εκλογική αναμέτριση αυτό είναι τεράστιον επίτευμα να λλάβουμε
υπόψηνο τις σε κάθε εκλο γικαι να μετρει η ψηφίζουν και λιγότεροι και έκανε και
μετά γραφές σεσαν κάπω δενώ επιο βαθμόν θα τουβγούνει μεταγραφές διότι ένα προσόν σισαγωγικά του
ελάμη ήταν ότι ήταν εξοσυστημικό προσωπικά δεν πίστευω την εξωσυστημικών αλλά μαγκιά τους εκαταφέραν να
πλασάρονται ως εξοσυστημικί το γεγονός ότι φέρνεις μέσα πλέον συστημικές προσωπικότητες μπορεί να σε βοηθήσει